alrighty team here we go it's finally
arrived
frexia all will be one complete edition
uh you guys you already know what's
inside the box but if you don't a bunch
of set boosters
aforexion frexian Arena awesome box some
sick lands and
the most important thing is the complete
edition booster which we're just gonna
dive into
so
if I can get this pull tab
here we go already gorgeous Alice norna
by gingi Ito everybody's seen this this
is the card we want to open we want one
we want one of these
literally
one of my favorite little bundle boxes
again gorgeous artwork
practice open
tokens more alishorn
Okay so we've got the awesome awesome
foil lands I can't wait to crack into
those
there's the forexian forexian arena
we've got our set boosters
and
thing that everybody wants the whole
reason why these bundles are going
through the roof
the complete edition booster pack
all right
let's do this it's 12 step boosters by
the way as well we'll do the set
boosters in a second but this is this is
what we want to see
all right so we get two oil slick Mystic
rares in here alongside
these gorgeous gorgeous lands so you get
two
of each because obviously planes
Island
swamp
Forest
Mountain
all right here we go
come on Ellison
we got sulfim Mayhem Dominus look at
that it's the
uh raised
oil art as well you can even feel the
border is raised
okay let's go Alison on or even Dominic
dominant would be freaking sick
oh
Toronto Rex
look at that artwork
not exactly what we wanted but
still gorgeous nonetheless
all right let's set these guys over here
you can see the awesome lands let's
quickly open some set boosters
maybe maybe we'll get an Irish norn in
here
Island
serum core Chimera drowned an echo
furnished Punisher
nahiri The Unforgiven and veraska's full
actually I'm I'll be playing this in
Excel
uh commander deck that's
really nice
all right one Mythic
oh I saw something spicy
Mountain
the commons incubation sack
unicuts retrofitter rib skiff
necrosquito
drummingbird
black bullied rat
encroaching microsynth
oh nice a what if
foil jaw kadine
and anything bonus nothing bonus with
that is really nice I love the Black and
White cards
all right
pretty good pretty good
oh snap that's a list card
art Forest
bring the end
coffee gleeful demolition exuberant
fuseling charge Forger
Brack's anointer
nice uh what are they calling the Stars
ink splotch gethine of contracts
awesome kaito dancing shadow
and our list card oh nice oh no knotless
card foil and we have a list
Maya convert
and
um oh it's um
the universe is beyond
um Ken I believe this is
no this is Ryu this is uh Vic Wikia
scorching stalwood uh this is the Ryu
secret layer card ah awesome
very cool very cool
okay Island
prolox tices mebwilder
transplant theorist atmosphere surgeon
prosthetic injector reject imperfection
bloom
oh
vicar Enigma Goliath I'll be doing a
Deck Tech around this card I freaking
love this card basilisk Shepherd
the token
let's move this up to the side
[Music]
oh nice gorgeous Forest
cataxian Raptor cataxia not on this
vivis Viva surgeon's insights
surgical Bay Surgical skull bomb why we
got Junior taxes pack here
armored scrap gorger
evolving adaptive cinderlash ravager saw
blade Scamp
and a blade of the shared Souls another
awesome Commander card anything else or
we've got a foil foil Cinderella Lash
ravager
pretty nice
all right Art card
very nice land
complete devotion molten rebuke Planet
disruption hazardous Blast Furnace
Strider
magmatic
Sprinter or a brass anointer
churning Reservoir saw blade Scamp oh I
see a foil nice bloated contaminator
and Vivid section evangelist anything
spicy nope
load of contaminator will take excellent
card
oh a signature Art card
swamp Whisper of the dross the dross
pits dross a skull bomb I feel like they
put the themes here
cruel uh grimnark font of progress are
we going surgical B cards now
transplant theorist
atmosphere surgeon I feel like it
definitely does it's a new dancer
thrummingbird
bloated contaminator again
and prediction steward
okay that's
what are the odds of that happening
Commander Phoenix
I can't remember his name
Forest
plague nurse
contagion Warwick pestilence siphoner
black belly rat oh
my convert
necrogen Rock priests necrogen communion
kanka bloom
necrogen Rock priest and
evolved spinoderm
and oh nice a foil armored scrap gorger
four packs left
it's like uber brass count
all right planes
tendon
I
Orchard
Prowler
sleeper immobilizer
logbook so we had tamios immobilizer
tamio's logbook
serving bird which features tamio
and
rust Vine cultivator oh
copperline Gorge fast land
oh foil dress dress never rotates out
dresses dress is always a good card
all right still no Alice Norm
Jace
perfected mind what if artwork Forest
infectious inquiry
a course bit basilisk gulping scrap
track stinging Hive master
void Wing hybrid tainted Observer
scheming aspirant unnatural restoration
rust Vine
cultivator and oh nice taivar jubilant
brawler
and
Oh I thought it was gonna be something
spicy then sinew dancer foil and oh nice
Commander card for Axion triniform
this is a very cool Commander card
nice we are gonna have to try and build
around that
okay Art card swamp Testament Bearer
Cutthroat Centurion chimney rabble
whoops prosthetic injector reject
imperfection vivisection evangelist
Quicksilver Fisher
full art or sorry borderless rager very
rager Razer Verge Thicket
oh
oh wow borderless
evolved spinoderm
and a red Sun's Twilight wow a three
rare pack do we get anything else spicy
oh my word oh nice excellent Commander
card in foil tiver stand
oh what a spicy pack
I'm going to rare file I'll be playing
that
okay last last pack last chance for
Irish non
-card oh nice foil full art incision
glider bone picker Scourge fleshless
Gladiator tyranoax atrocity it's a new
dancer necrogen Rock priests necrogen
communion I feel like we get those two
cars in a row canker bloom
it's a new dancer
ah Flight of the shared Souls again
a double rares in these packs and final
card
scheming aspirin no list card
well there we go we do have
one more of these packs to open do we
open it let me know in the comments down
below
don't forget to leave a like And
subscribe if you enjoyed the content
stay tuned for more Commander content
coming soon thank you so much for
watching
see you next time